F
OFTAFFEEO GRG W.H BUSEC RLSAL
1sETH 4IDPRt ESTEN
PRTIIDESENIFAL LEAT REDUL FL
DUSCHEOR ILENFTIMAONS I OINNLE
E APPLG. .TVOR
OKOUO S YGR PRROAM GDEUI.
ESA  PR OENIDT TFHERA LIB.RY
IBNA[IUD].LE
YOANTHK  M SUOORHUC F JNIOINGS U
O
S TRHIHTON TIGGR P'SROH WAMIT
UTLCA ABORHO A HUTISEW NK. BOO
FROMNEOR FTUINAG MAZAY RE TEHES
DIGUAR M AANNDTHYAN OS.ER
I
LS AO
WA TNTOHA TNKTH OSERSE WHO
USNEGEROIBON CTR HIOUTNSEAT
MSOGPRRAIKEHESEBLOS PSI
E.F
EOU Y'R MOT N A PBEEMR,ASLEE
IDCONSNI JEROI.NG
ANUYO CINDS U ON OUR WSIEBTE
AN A IOLSAK TEHE TE TIM TO
TH
RAKIN CES JIGONOR FKE MAR
I
TANDAVYHE HEDEL HPE US ALLEA YR
BEVENER E AENBLO TTA SYD WOUE'V
DECNNTEYRE PTTHAO S T YNKOU
AG
ORNAI FLL A OF YREL HP
TYPRETSOP CIE OF J'SIMOO BK ARE
AALSOLEILVAABN O A W.SIEBTE
ANO ADLSIA D'SNEOO BK ANDE W PUT
A
IIN LKNHE THA CT.
AT EELSO DE WE HAV OURAMRO PGR
WIECE B R ADEORDNDL WILEN SD A
LI.NK
OINURW-OL FLOUPAI E-MLND A AOLS
ACGR AUSIOLYWERIOUE QST SNSO
ANUYO CSE UHESE RAIR YOUAN HD
U
ITINCONN THE BTOOTMF OHE T
NDENRE A WE W LLILETOU YSK A
YO
ST QURUETNIO A THEND E OF
N'JES
AL TK.
SAND NOOW ITS I MYON H TORO
INUCEOCALENES RIDTEN J
BECAMP HOSD TIO NHEATLNA
ATNDSYICEDAD RIOHO S IN W
HIT
AMNJE CELPBL.
14 J90PH ANDAR HINHID-TT
TEIN LIERVWSDIEANG FURIGE.
IBNA[IUD].LE
PO ITILICSSCE FORDNT PRI IEDN
FITHE TRSCU EXEVETIVINT IEREW
FO NEREWOR YK GREROVNOT A T
E
IOGNSIATEDPRN AYN I THEIR FST
RVINTEW IEISEO C.
NA[I].IBUDLE
[I].IBUDLE
F TINHEROSTIR B ICAADSTEWERNTVI
I
LY ATHNAND,ST A GOVNMENT IN
M
HICERAN.TOISRY
K THANUYOEN J FOROI JNGNIS U AND
WEE.OM
>> YANTHK I AOUND H MSYOR A
EEI SOM SEEO PEPL INIEC ROG
ZEU
RE TTHEARO S PRCUTILAAP HPY
TH
T MEOS CRE AING OUTF OHE T
NIY WATOT.GH
FENEV I GT' ISNGOIO TOU YR
LIM. RNGOO
EMEDDDEO SHA TTT IS IO SE NIC
H
E JPEUMD OUT ANDEDNV IITE M
AT T MINHEEUT TOO B WK
AS
INGO. OGUT
TIN BHEOYUT SCONS I THERYIB LRA
T
T AC.NDNKHA YOUOR FIT INVGIN
MEEC DNDIRFRTO O T LHE
RY
FONGVIINTIUSE M JT GO RDEA
WE AGOE TSEEV RERASTK. WEE
SO IEDON HOR IT TOHIO D TS.
I TNKHIPL PHEEOEOIRE A G TNGO
AKNOWHEUTBO TAD MTOUPE- SYHRY
ITDESPTHE EAC FT TTHAHE T
NERAPERC ITIEPON OSNE GUY
OP
GATERINEHIN ATA CURIN WHO
PU
FFEDLL O AIG B ONEM SCHE AND
ALACTU W HLYEASAB DISD OR0 4
E
AS ARIINLL KDS OFAY WSM FRO
SP-CCOONSATIRORLLY GCOS I.
ERPORERT M A:SNVORAJ I WTOESRSHO
ACAILYAL BLHE TMUT
N O
SIOCCA C AONNDEAMO TOW PER TO
ORRESTEIM H.
ANLLLLWIFUND BYLI
CIPINSRAEDS,ST HD, FGEUN
T
THALL EON M.EY
I  TLLHEIT UNWNGTI
NSPI,TORARSIV FE
STINVENSATIGIO THA TTAVYHE HE
NEDO.
HIRE TDWOLO FSORND UERIS HH
SSSIBUNEH WITOP TOT NIN BCHUSSES
SCDU GOLRAOEAT SHI TS ISIN KD
OFOR WD. WLDIN
OOW H TIVEOU Y MYE
IR FT
TIQUEST TONHAAY A ILW HS TEAVO
AN T IERSETHA WAD HOT N TNGHIO
DOINHIT FNGDI AEER BNI DTHEA.
TANDTHA IAS WOM CGIN HEOMRO F
M
NGHAVIEENPCE SIN 430 IN THE
GRNMOINGUR DINHE TNI MORNGW SHO
TATHENT IIOSEERCTN O THECH BEA
N
POD STOA RD.
ANDNI BERE MEADFF OAS PWASSE A
Y
ICAPPLUNLEAB HAREDDR YM FDSRO
THHE STALL SONTI I WAS GNGOIO T
STETND A G N HISK.
SHO PNERTTASO TDEXP ELOND A
TE
NDSXT AHO PNE CLSAL.
AN IM AOL TD TNTHA OLO B
G
ORADIND AEN TESIN MUT ANDHE T
N
EA AITLROU ADYNNNEDNC I ON THE
WEOEIT S I HAD TO SO GNGINPRTI
HOOO T D A SEVUT MINE
THEY ANE KWTUTBO IEF B IEORID D
N
N TDHE IOT GHE TEW NOR YKOS PT
Y TDHE MSK AEDEO T WRIHI TS
INIDHE MEDLF OVINT IER NSEW
W
OSRKYO PED ATSKOE M TRI WTE A
20 WORIC ADRT ILENHE T
OOTEAFRN T FNORT NHEEX D'S
R PAPEHEATTH TRDI ETOD SAIHA TT
HE POU WLDUT IN T FHENT PAGE
OF ILD WOU GETT ION DE.
ASI W LEAEIK HVYAI RN00 20
WOS.
IN SSHI TRTHOEPA SN.
TYPRET IAI SDS F ONEIVR OIX S I
T GOTOUF O BED ANDOO LTDKE A THE
YONEW RKT POSPP AS I THE NBEUMR
TRONE  ADIENNG IICRTLENHEIM TE
THSS G IUE AOR ME OF THE
D BLTAOI CTESIS TLEALDHEAILY
FILMA ONON LDODAL CLE MNDE A
DASKEE M IF IW KNE WHO WAS
TTGEHEGIN TOD BYRO FM T BEAU
OFSO PRIN.
GH[LAUR]TE
SDAN IOUDAI YRE ANGID KDI ME
RI
TRE PNDCTDI AHE TYAI SDO N
EREYTH W'TENDI KID.NG
N'I DOW KTNOUE I GSSHE MOTREIO
ZABIE OS.
TU P AICT TREHA WASN I ONE OF
THIC AERTOUS,LE YAY MAV HEN SEE
T
ND AT I SADWSHO M OEFRG CHAGIN
00$70N INE OTH MON ONHE T
ORATCREDITAR CD.
DIT KSNOE'T MWNOHAE T STHE
AOUABTON PZIEM SCHE BUT LKOOT A
THBAIG PGYVE PCKRE ANTNYTEI WGH
THICOT G PD UY BNE O
TADD OIAN IHE TN SAWLL A OF
D,WOE RLHELL A TIC ASERT
SLE
NGCOMINDN I A INIEC ROGZE,70 500
A CDIRETNIEC ROGOMZE SEGNOR FEI
LAENGEUA TON SNISHNND A O
N
D ON.
SO OOT N ONEFHE TPL SAME
S I
EEDLL MO TIN FD O BUTUTHE TRE
WE A70 500OS ALLCRHES T.OR WLD
SO WOW NLILO GAC BKO T01 21ND A
HA THI TSVENGHI ERAP HNED.
TH KON D'THOWNO W IM A.
LLDAN AF O AUD S BNDENIERES I
GLKTAINO T ME.
BORFO A EUTHTIGRS YEA ANDAS I W
IN THE DAYEF BEORHE TUT ARHO
EDWOD RK TIT WHHE FILAMYAI SD
ATHATREND AAD M OEFFH WIT
TA
EEDLK MFF O OFHE T RECD.
SO
IDAL CLEIM AND IDI REALY
JU O AEDLLIMRVE H
FAI SDHEATRIV GEOU Y ALLHI TS
TONEMOY UY B A CNDOPO- AAS LT
NTMOH FORHI TST WENN O TO DID
U G TTHAON M BEYKACIG RHT
AAWAY INDN THEIN SBSG AY.UTOLEL
ME SEYEEDER VYN OPEND A
EDSWANERNY A IANTED TODY BRA
HEDAN T OHO SWSNROOM TOR HWE
IDSAIL WLE WAY S ITIVEND A I
WINIS LTEFND A I SOU YAYHE T
HIMESA T ING'MNG GOIO TAK ME
SUHATOU DO.
SOTE LEISNDNE IECHE T SDON
DEINCOCIHIENC W EVEBODY
GHS OWRITE HERLR A WDYEAAS
THRU WASIN MOV HGIS MHEOTR FMRO
IDFLOR AAND O IERFFEDO TAK TE
HE T ORUTOR.IN DNE
Y ASONDAI SDHNO EUGF O THECH BEA
EHOUS WHA TTAS INBEEC DEMRND A
TH N WEAS OONE IN THE
RENTAUSTRAOTE W GRE THE SND AHE
R
INVERID  COM SESSLAESHI WE
I
E NDOTAKNVE T OEFFNS IEIDF O
STE THRE FRAAUNTHI AOR WLEHE TN
RDESH OHAEDER TP STHI SADALND A
PSHEEDCEROEDEVO T DR IIK LE
NE SHIS SOTORNEE F. YOU
ED EWEND UP H ITIITNG OTND
WSHERE IASNC NBLDIYE.IC
OD CRYMIHESTE WE WERKI WALNG
NDTOU A IAI SD, CANOU Y A
ECTPIURND A SHE S APPTOEDNDHE S
YSAIDIRROU WN' AEDRE YTOUHE S
GHTHOUAIIT  SHT RDIGUT BNC OE I
COERCEIN H IHA TTAS WOT N
ISREWID  CUS JTATVEONRSFFNIO O
E RE SRDCO,KE HHEOO MDEP U
THWINI BERE.
K TDOO TBO AUTKS WWOEE OF
E-
TILMASORO PVEO TOM CE
STHGEER ID TOLNI BEREND A
IDSA TYHEE HAV V FCHOUEDOUOR YR
ITNCSIER'MSOY  IOI GNGO TK TAL
OPOU Y H TULEFLYISO D TLPEHE
S MYTHOUT TS.HI
THISE  AIS MTIRCPEEP.ON
ELLTE MIS HONER VSIF OTYEA RLI.
RODAN IYCANILLWND AREAD MEFF O
MA OFFECN O D10BEEMR ,th
IERNFE CONFTEDSS A
NOERON
REBEFOE W ADESRRTEY B THE
AFBI,DITDMTEEER BNISSON CFE
ED
ANAND  NEWDREREVAI STH ADNOER
SID WLEOR HO TISHE FATVER E
R
N.AGAI
SUAER BOWENI B AERSHRENDW,E
INWAS GAK MIN YOU NWOETRK
SOINTHG.
EER BNIND A I GOAC BKND ATH FOR
PVESENEAGAN HENRIDWTTND A
WRETGIN LSRSTE AEL WLS A
ILE-MA HWAS S A HEADETR SOK
TH A AENDUTBO00 4AG PESND AS I
WHOW T GEOTORE WHEE WOT G.
REFIGUHAUT O WOT TO DT IOT GTITH
.THIS
IRIEREV WENTT A BK.OO
IN ATGAN ANT AGE WEHEEA SRCD
ARORNDOU FSHUB PLIERND A G IOT
AN
AHEOTRNDNTGE AE HOL SDT I
INDESI ATR CONTACENS IIDNE O
EKWE.
WISASEDTA SRTT IND A ID TOL
IEBERNHA TT IOU WLDTE WRI DOW
EVLESIY NG AOR WD S HNDEDAI I
PTACCEHO TSETION CDINDSON A
TH
'S WT H. DEID
LHA TT UDSEASP UO THE TTO SRE
W.NO
T TIRYVE COONST FYIR O,FFHI TS
WANT EANVET THANEAP HPES TD,HI
BEPUT ENTO SEDPP INIV FEESIN MUT
N
DHR TEENTFEIFREAY WS
AT
T.LEAS
.... . A THE CPICOO-NS ITORARS
H
E VIOUSAY WS G ISSUE H
EWO
VED ULHA BAUNEE CTGH
RE
LYTILAVEUI QLY.
THEOTRHANGHI TRISUT RPSSE
IOPPELEOR N TLLMAYAR WHEIZ
DBE
NDHIURHE T C AINTANDN IHI T
SECAEER BNINAS W O 1 THEH7T
EHROO BDIN LKEOCDOO DRS HISFL
OWN DON SSHAN'IDT ES AVECCSO T
END ANTH9THE T 1RFLH OOHA TT W
S
100%IMEG LITNDEAT AHE TY A DID
TRE FORCO DISROTUN BRSKE
OKINFOR F THEMIR LEIK
ABSCHW
NY AE'Y,WA HSNS DOWANIRTAS D
IN
INRU TSTGHE T T GUYDET HAMA
ALL THE WON MEY WHOAS T
HE
ESBIGGTF OHE T BIG ANDOOK
LI B$7IL O OONUTTHF AT HGEED
NDFUHA TTS ITIIN NE HASME WT
BE
ADIERN M OFFTO SLE INHE T
BUHESSNE WIT H WASINAVG
TRUTESBL BHE TAM FYIL
OUOBVIY TK A  MT LOOFEYON
TOUHE WTHN EYE WERARIS DCHNGGI
,05700 ATH MON
THET 'S OHET  TNEHALLIDPA A
TH
E MEYON T ANDTHEEHR OSERH EAC
PALI B AILONR OWO TS AEL WL.
TH
MOE ST UMAATNFHOHIEBL TNG TO
AS W W YOULDOUHI TNKALOG LICLY
THATT WHAAPPED ISEER BNI IS
TINNNGSHI AND IS H
HLIGYU
RDREGAH  WEDITTOGURELAWA ORSN
L
ETSTRE.
HE TRESIS HUS CMETORSH WIT
GRPE RTESCTND AOU Y
OU WD
THINTHSOK MEADGIN BUS MT HEAV
EDPPHAEN.
HEUS MHAT VEOS LT SONEOM M AEYND
WH I IETEG'TSN LALE HAY SS'M I
O
GIN TOUC BEKLOW DN, CCHATP, U
ATY PAWHEREVPE HAP G ANSND
ETBA
CK TOMA NORL.
RNBEIE MOL TDTOAE  SRY JKET USLI
TTHATTHAE HAD HEV NER TDOL
YYBANODLS EE, NN EOTVE HIS
AWYLAER HIS L IYEAWRPO SKEO T
E
BUSCAEWANIERE DVEHEO T T
-CRNTOEY PENLITGEVIRILECH WHI
SU UISNU AALS YOUNO KW.
SO IAI SOKD AY S AOTEA LST
SERTHE' LOM SEVEICOG EGHTHN OU
YOAD ME AISTAKEEC BTSEAU I
WASRI CNAMIL TORT STANGET BTI
EVHIYTNG AND RDEAHE T
NSFORES R.OREPTS
IDAL TKEO THE TBI FKR B,AN
Y
LOAND W ANDD,EH BOL A TTHEE SAM
TIE H WLD BASUIISG INTH
SU BSFESULSINUSESHATAM BECE
ETHR UM NBERETHEM FRO ZOKO ERBR
H
POMOE NO T OLYF Y NHEEWKOR
ENTE ORIRPSEWAN LLTR SN TEE IETH
MESA TIM TE DREHE'SNTFEIFRE
OFPETYS YEMP ELOHI HESE DREOR F
CHEA.
OUHE FNDES HONTEEO PPL HDCOE UL
A
TEPUNILAND A WN' DHOIDT
TADEUNRSNDT WHA HEAS WOI D.NG
YOAN CGI IMA HNEOW
COENARMPTMDLITAZE HISIN MD. WAS
THIT LEG BATIMEINES WAS
H WORTIOMI3 LLINN ND AF O IELTSF
E AASNYVELUXCSIED HGEUN FD SO
ETHES GOU FRSUYAM CHA TEO VE
TH TOW PERYHE CXTLDOU ETOR
RNRETUS,E HRE GW TOAT HE TMHE
INAND SE S AENT I WAS R A
E
RO BHON OD HAUECSE HEAD
A
BOLWHEF CHUN OATWH IOU WLDAL CL
AVEAGIGOT N HHWOH RTNV I
S
INPUTTEY MGONTN I I O0RVE 3R O
RS Y40EA ORA AFVEGELT WEAHUI BLT
VEUP ORIM TE.
ONETH PZICHEMEASAS W E
TYO
CTDETEY B W THEAU BAYECSE ALL
YOAV HEO T ASKHES I WRES IHE T
O
Y,NE AREOU YNGRA TDIIT WH
Y,YBANODHO WOURE A Y TRANGDI
THWI.
CHT NOMUOR MEHA TNHA TT.
WHSE' B THEKAN A.OUCCNT
DO H YOUE AVAN ACCNTAN B ATNDY
ETHAY WHA H,E DN A AANOUCCNTT
A WOAS-M ONEAN SALIPTR ML NOTH
EVIC LSEEND T DO G PLIUBC
TICOACUN.NG
ATNT PNEOIE HAI SEB SDOMYOD
ALLDOU C TLO FDIN OIT IUTF S IH
AH  WARASDANURT I TDNE
OUT
ITHATWAT S AROAU LNDT.MA
WHEASO ALSTENV IESD BIT WHNIE
O
ON NE OF SHE TSEPLIMEES T
TSE
E  DREONHYDAN W ISHA TT, WE
GWILLTOO HE T. SEC
EYTHDU CONIVEDCT FRASEE PATE
IN
ATSTVEIGNDNSIO AEV NER
UNREVEDONHE T PZIEM SCHE OR
7TETH 1OR FHLOER N,EVYEA RLL
FIUTDRE O THA TTREY HEWE
CHGIARNG HH  WIMITETHAM SE
NSOFFEHAE TAR CTLE HIMHE T
BTIME
OREFE.
TTHEY HUGHOHTDOWAE S GIN
FRNGUNTRNI
'SAT YHE WN AOUREKE MAR
UMRKE JNGPIIG R IHTN IN FNTROMA
R YOUMEUS CTOUSBER CAE Y IFOU
N
Y TOWHERE A TOI GNGORDE HE
KNT WSHAUSHE T CMETORS IOI GNG
DTO YOUUMP IIG RHTTFRN ON
OF
CAT  IBEOUEUS YNO KW THE
IRKMAETGGOS IN T GP. U
ATTH T H'SOWHOYHE THTUGE HAS W
ABLEO TRA GUAESEENT RTSUL
ECABEUSE HW  KNEASATWH W GNGOI
ON.
THE NNY WHI TNGASE H NEREVID D
T FRON ANEMOYNDER NEVNC OEOU W
VE DHAEON TTO HTO CISUS
.
ANWE CAL TUT AKBOOB RD HINOOF I
ODANYBSY'RD HEA BAUECSEY' THEVE
USABIR TEDHEMEUS CTO IRSN A WAY
ATTHNI BERER NEEVOU WLDAV HE.
>>,SO ATHS EYTHIS MS
EIN
ATSTVEIGFTNIO AER
ATSTVEIGHEN,IO T S AREREEOM
WHWEEBTLLORSKI LOOTH ANGT
STNGTI IN L THE0sE AT'9ND A
[I]IBUDLE
DUNN'IDT NDRSDETAAR HRYND A
IDEYTH DT WA TON IS LTETO
M.HI
EYHO TE HTUG HS A
LERUSGNTDTIOM CPER.TO
TBU TO GOUEIV YE SOMLEXA EMP
RE A ISAY WHA TTHE TOUEC S CLDSE
A
VE SVEOLITD  F INEIVUT MIN
EN
IEBED RNMEOL TD  G HESE AVHI
ACTUN NANBEUMR D THE
TOPODESIRY TOMSTRU CNDNYPA ALL A
AVUYO HNOTOE  KISW  ALL YROU
HADTRESOEAV TOHR T
GHOU.
HE TAV GEHEOU ACCBE NNTUMRCH WHI
A
S 0ND664 A THEAR MTKE MING
NESISSTHVE ERYOUGIN C BLDE
TR AEDNDHE TY T DIDT HANO
MOBPRLEO S HES GEIVHE TMHE T
NUER AEC ENDXPTSTOHE TM SK A
OK
W AERE CLIALNGBO A HUTIS
IN
NTSTVEME AYISDVORUSINS AN
E
RE AOL TD ITS I T 646
ACNDTUN AHE TYLD WOUAV HE
FOD IUT O MFIN VEUTINESRE THE
WA NOUC SHOU ACCNTNYR O A
MEVEINSTIS ANTDVRYOR OZI PON
THESCME EDIRANGORVE T
GO
UGTHROANH D GSSUEHA WT,
HE Y
'TDIDN TAK MEHEHO PL CNEAL ENVE
TEAFRE H TAV GEEM HETH
ATFOINRMN.IO
'SIT PTTREYMA A
NGZI.
THE WHIOWLESTBLSERW. KNE
THAT STRHAYEG TDESOT UNDY VER
CO
LEMPX I NOU CLDINEREV FDNY A
OFISTI VIC OR ENHE T
TRERS OUOWH CLA ELDXPTO IINT
ME I BUT U YFOUOOERNDSTITD
EPCONC IALTULYWASY VEREIM SPL
UL SITHO LHAD VE TEROWEDCK SHETO
MA WCHHI MNSEA H
HLIGY
ELCORRHIEDAT WNS MCHEAOS MOFT
MEE THTIT I SULHODER PRMFO AS
THTO SCK MKEARTOE D
WEAY HOUE CUR FLDIGOUE TH
INWITH HWO TASRSOU WE H FTNDOU I
WA AYUACTLL% 5N IER OTHOR WDS
OUIT C DN'LDTTH AONYGIN B
NE
HA ASAD IDND TY BHEAY W I
TCO
HDNUL'TEAVUPON GE VE ERY
MO
H.NT
HE HEV NER AADAT NEGONEIV MTHN I
R  O30EA YRSO SHE T SYATTREG
NER MEAD SNDSEEN AEO  NON
AP
LYREPANTID.
HE W A DREIDS TLLHI CON MEYEOM
FROMHA TT WASNG GOI TO HISGE HED
?FUND
ITNG GASOIO T THEREE FDEUN FDS
TDSEHE A WHOS JSEOBT I
S
AYTO SAV I HE THEON MEYHE SS I
RYVESE CONEATRVIV'M I GNGOI T
LOOKSCR AOS FR EIV OXSI
POFOLI P AOSNDUT HER MEYON
WI
CT ETHXAT WLYHAS  FITRHE
OBESCTJEIV.
THIN ODS WEROR O L AOTF DUE
DI TNCGEET HAIROMID BOREFE
I
HAK TEER MEYONND AHE SLD WOU
OMELFE CLERTFOAB TND ARUNHE TSST
E
TO  TPUONER H MEYN IIR THE
.IN
NET RUROR FT, THAHE T HGEED
NDFU CHAESRG IMA NTSOREEL F
HICONVE ERYEWE OS US
%  F
TSASSE 2 AND0% TND UERGE HHEED
APNDFU CALITND AAKT I TEST JUS
1%
OR DENIL DIG ACENDEL HNGPI
DTOODM AATISINTREIVK. WOR
TH WGUE YSHETHA TENDE UP
BINDOG, DNIEREN'IDTLL AOWNY A
DUE DCEIGILEN RHI WCHFFHTIG O
THE W BATSKLDOU AOUHY W WLDY THE
ACPTT. THA
YBMAEEC BESEAU HSE PASD ON ALL
OSTHETIUC LRAS FVEEEIHA TT
NENTMEIODAC BTH TKO EREE FDE
FU BASALICLYO SHE TLD WYOUTN'
YK ASANIOUE QST.NS
SOE H WASAS BALICLY TING MEYON
NOIN, OTEE FS RHEHA TAL SNTEGIN
ITS A AON PEM SZICHE G ANDINIVG
HUDSRELLF  OBINSIOF ORSOL DLA
TOEEHE T FNDR DEFUSND A AHA WT
REKB KLYICFKSAC IOU YIL W
LWH
HIC TALYHE C AFEL ESND IN
RERNY THETID DN'SK A ANY
ONESQUTIS.
T OIDYNL DHE TYOT NSK A
QU BONTISNI BUTERE MEAD EHAC
OFM THEANIG SN  ANTEEGRMEHA TT
TH
HEYADO N DIOCRISETTH ONN E
STINVE
NTME.
HEAT T SEAMIM T HEED TOLHEEC S
EATTH HOAD H NISCRIOETNHEN O T
INS,MESTNT FHE T FDEEERDSUN
DDI AND ALLE HSID D IXE ETECU
.ADTRES
SOOUAN CEE S YOUAVE THEEC S
SSMIVEG ININIOIGSTATNS
EV R
NGHAVIHE TIG RHTPL PEOY THE
RNEVEDOO LKEGHHR TOUHE TK LOOHRE
INIVIGSTATIPOE NZEM SCH,ES
VENERSKINNI BGERANE Y
QU SONTISHEO TY WLDOUUS JT
T
NESFE IUR RET FNSORGAK TIN
LE'SON MEYND A TFT OENESIMPE
NO
N ETVENGEL TLI THE TMYHEER WE
U
ITINTTG IT WHISDS FUN
.TH
EY SER WED POUPSE BTOE
VEDID.IFRSIE
ILILHO SWOMOU Y S SEINDELIS  A
D THOTHA S H HWOWEDUL PLEHI TS
BOFFEUT H HAD AMA SFF SLLTA ON
TH F7T 1HORLOHE TSEE WERIG HH
OLSCHO GRA,ATDUESTID DN'
TADEUNRSL WNDALEE STRT.
TH WADTRESLLEER A AAK FE
NDTH
EY D RN'IDTLIEAZET I WAS
GAILLE N ALNDEAEREV RZELID IT
SWA PONECH SEM IN 4RS Y0EA
USDAN JTOT HO SW YOUE OW H HEWKN
WHO TO HISEIR HIN ADMIVTRISATE
ASWHANSTT  WOASD G AOORC SOU
F
MNEIN O TLOHE FOR00S I 1
%HOR
HSTNE,EAI PD12 $ A005,0
WITHO NRA I.
SHID D A T OLLFHEHO PNY
TR
INADG.
HERAS LT YR.EA
RHE0, $67AL000 SDY ARANHE S HAD
MI$5A 8 IOLLN IT RA AETHE SAM
ASBJO B SALICLYO Y UNDSTAND
SYWHN' DHEIDTAT LKOR N DES OESH
EVUR FIG B OEDUT AAUECSE
F
MOHER ASYNE W I F TNHEM WN
ENIT WT DN S SHEID DTN'
W
ASIT W AON PZICH SE.EM
'SITNGLO BWIP U. NOW
THEOL FKSAV HE LTOS,ON MEY
19ONIL BLINDHE TY T
UGT
THEY HBI 6AD5
IOLLN.
SOOU TO NUR TECETH SSITURIE
ANES INVENTMTRO PNCTTEIO
ATRPCOORHEN,IO TALQU EIVFTEN O
THBI F. C
FTHES C DIHAROENBE AINDUN SCE
EWETH N AEA DLND HASEV N
EDFAIL PO T M TAYHEHAEYON TT IT
TYSSA IWESP TO TTHAIM LIT TO
ANYNVESR ANDEV NER TOS CTS
.
ER GS.OVENNMT A DLAOLR.
PCE N  OTHHAHEOTR N' DNDIDT
LLTEEO PEPLY THEID DTN' IEND
OVTO C AERON PZI SEMCHE.
THEYD SAIHERE'S NL ROEA
INMESTNTIV ACTO YIT S'T CWEAN
GO FAN IORT HEFUD RTORRMEREE W A
NO TINGOGOOG RECZENIHE TIN FAL
ENATSTEMT.
G AWERENGOIO T RZEOGECNIY ONL
TH OLGIRINATMNV IESTEN VUEAL.
SOMA INEGIOU YRE AER MLL LCH
P
INENGP UOU YR SNTTETAMEND A
GNDFIINUT OHA TTUM NN'R BEIS
TRE
AALND FMOTHURERT TREHA IT
TESDON' IENNTDO T IOV CERT
D
THATHE TYN' DID EAV HE
UGNH
Y MONETOOVERT. I
BU FOREA6 1 YOR BRSEFNI BEERE
OWNTWE DN TTHAY THEACKE
MOUENGHEYONOEAN HDLHE T
BR SAGEREO WOTHA DY THEO, D
NONE O D TE IMOFHENTAY PME
SCA
O OMEUTF THEUN FD.
ANYIC VATM TITH WAD HWNHDITRA
MMOREEYON TNHAHEY T IN
AFR TRS YHEEA TOUYHE WLD
CKAWCLBAON MEY.
TH LAS CEPO SAWUPEDRTHA TT,UT B
LOA TICF O VOTMSTI NNL OY HEAV
ETH TON MEYEYT HATHOSE'V LN ETVE
OUTHGH OR T Y 3HE0HERSEA TY
Y MAADVEHA H MO NEFEYON LBUT THE
EY HIR TADHEES HOMND ARA I,
ATHE ARAVEGE OGE AIC VASMTI W
75EARSNDLD-O AOM SE OM TFHE
ODHA T G ABAO CKK WNDOR IN
WANDTAR A T LNGHISEIKHA TTND A
STIMEHE T'TDIY DNAV HEHE TONEY
TSTNELYPAO Y TMHEK BACHY W
LDSHOUEST N'THETONV IESRSAVE
CABASILEYLL CEDAR B ANIERE
NDTGI A AT THE SEAM THIEIM TSE
WAS GN,NGOI O T.R THE.A.
PRMRA WAS P $TIUTNGLL0 80BINIO
N
WALTTR SEE AIR FMSTHT E
SAIM TE TOP KEEHE TM AVELI
THILWHE IMVIE CTS WTENOW DN
UGTHROCOTHH E T PINCEROEDGS
EARFO YRSVE OREY MONHAHA TT
DBE
EN CLEALD BK.AC
NOW TREHE ISNE OTH OERA AREHAT
AL TSOOTLY MOFSEISD HI TS
NZPOICHEMEND AHA TTS IIS H
BA. J,.P MGAORN.
OTHEYNLY NT EITREYWANHEHA TT
ULCOINSED E TO A HIS AOUCCNT
ND
WHOUCH NEY SWAEA RHEYLL T,RE
HED TOLEE M H NADEREV HOR ME
5.ANTH $IOBI9 LLNEPN O DNDITOS A
WHAS WLE CALD 7 THE03CC ANTOU,
H
TLAE STIGEEHR DS.IT
THWAES RT S SPOSEBE TDO N I
TH
ETMAE RK O WASAK FEZI PON
DTHEY EN'IDTDEN VEUN ITARSNDT
WA
FSORNVHE T IT TMESENVISO
THEY T IUGHOHTAWAT S IMEG LITEAT
MRKMAETINAKG AOUNT
VE EN
GHTHOU ITAD HN BEEK B AAN ONEF W
FRKOR 3RS Y0EA AFND I YOU
HA E AVEN SITQUYATEG THAT I
S
EQUITEIM SPLO T TAY SANHE BK
UNACCO GHAT S TOTOW SHO PSMEAYNT
TFORDERA, COURTERNTPA AY,ND
GIT'SOT TW  SOHONDVIDIDEETHS ER
SH HAVN BEELL4  $BIN IOOF
VIDI BNDDESH OTIN TS AOUCCNT
AN
ME PDAYOSNT TOU CRTERNTPASIE
PNSNOTOADNS ITE0  $,17NLLBIIO
HROTHUG TCCTHA ANTOU,
BI170
IOLLN.
WAERTHE NE'TSN O DOLFRLA O
DIVENDDE EOS DREPEDITNER O O
TYMPAENOOU A CRTERNTPAYVE ER
MAND A M.P J.GAN VER
VEUNCOATD RETHHAND A T ITS
Y
E ONOFHRHE T TNG TEEHIS J..P
SRGMOANEWCRED UP.
WITEN TKS TOALIT WHIE JAMIM DON
WHOS IHE TFEO C O.P J. MGAORN
DW NOANGO'V IE  TTOL TEL YOU IT
E
ISEDST HHA C.CTRAER
I HSK AED I IIMF COMLDOU C IEN
DAN SOAKPE T THE PPLEOEHE TRE
UG TENHO.  JH.P
RGMOANEV
METO D I ANDT JUSHI TSEE WK I
REOFFED G TOEIV HIM B A AKOOND
LDTO HOU IIM WN'TE IDULNSTE
IFEITLE BW  O.FF
TBUASE H HAK TENOOHE T B AANK DT
SATHE MEIM T HEIS TLA CIMOE FAM
ISYHESE RAI 1D4AC BKO SE H
CL TMSOE BHE T SOS MTFUCEUCSSL
IPONZECH SEMESPI THEAC FTE H
O
THT EON MEYRO FMER OTH
VI
S.IM
USCAE THE IRU TTHMOS RETEE TESIE
COXLE HHA TNTRIEO TLA PARY.
1THATIOBI4 LLN HK TEOO
LI B$2ILVI IONN EN ESAXPSSEFF O
THOP TF OT. THA
ATE CAMF UT O OETHC SIPD. FUN
T
LL S'STIIL 2 BHAONLI T CLDOU
ONVEHA G IEN M MYHEDIN TUL BKF O
ITO T IHE TRSESNVTOLOHA TT ST
ALEITHRON M.EY
INETH FNG TALHIEEF BOR I
HOW
YOUOMES,LI SDES THICH SEEM IN
AYNYMA WS WAS ALS AOAX TRA FUD
SC.ME
ETHER WWOEER TOM CESSP CONACIRY.
SEON IHE TYER WE DAJNGOI M
WTHEYALEER CNGLI UPND A TNHE HE
WOL CDALUR DAXGIN TSO SEA
D
ISAYEE ND TSEHE KWO TF DIN OSHI
OFTCEFI AHE TE. GAT
ASNE O H BVE ERNEECURO PSEDTE
ALIMCRIN FLYOR TT.HA
NONEF OEDHE T HD FGEUNAG MANSER
WHOID D T D DHEUECEIGILEN AND
INLEMBD VEAD H ER BNEE
NALIDNARI CMIY.LL
ETHER OTHHI TNGAS W
ATTEINRNNAIOLREE FDEUN FDSND A
INONE CUAR PTIUR LAYOIL WL SEE
THCTURAT LERN, O IBLRENCDIE
AMSNTDI OF  MYRTEYONTHN I OER
HESRD TE WYER MOI DNGEYON
RIUNLADENG T FORHEANUS RSI
OLNDCHAR A CANOMOLBIRU DGD LOR
MOTO THEEN EXTY TTHE
THENATED J..PN.OR MGA
AGNOVHE T GTNMERENECID
TVENEROFTO G ASE TERHEKS FOL
IDANS L ADATLITE SERNGOUO T
AGOHEERFT TS GSEUY OUT BTHE
OT
ANRHE HTD IAS WEG ILL.AL
IEBERNAID  MEE HN' DIDN ETVE
KN W WHOAS T IN
IORNTEATL FS.DEEER'HEIN
RMREFO TANS DNHE I WLILW SHOOU Y
SSOMEDES Y AND A COUANSK SE
U
S.TIESON
WTRSIN AASN ALVIDIDU
NDI
DTRIEAYO T SHA TTY THEEEDO T
LINTHKEIK D ATOOCR INMS TERF
HTHATATPOIPCRIC
AT OH.
BONOER UDYNDWHOOSTD NI BATERE
WAOI D.NG
THSAEC NESSSLYRI AHEEUM T
GONTRNVEMEINS  IGOETOG  BRE THE
.
DTHEY HN'IDTEAVHE T FUN TO
RE PRSBUEPLEOE ANDTID DN'EE F
H
ATHE TE WYERATBL OIGCE SEDIN
ASIT W P ACHZION SEEMO S YOU
YOURNVWN O ITSTMESEN A IN.EN SSE
O
UEE ND B TOERCOE NSTIVAVEND A
TADEUNRS INDT.
HE T M HKEART GEONP U%  9A
YE
AR F 1OR00 YRSEA.
RNBEIEAS WAY PGIN A1%UTBO 1N
TH FAS LTEW YRSEA.
ENRRTTUF BFELD WOUAY S I
T
ODPERI RALICLYLYULEGARND A A L
DEINX FDUN ANDAK TE 9HA TT
D
PSLEE NT A
HTIG.
IN T E,NDUN H OEDDRSLEPEF OP
RALITEYLLNL OAY ANDF A DIDND
ERENWH BENI P ASEASD WY WAITAS
E LINTAS SRSE GLPEONN INRI PSOTH
FO WTHA ISIGHE T BONSTGE P
ZI
SCMEHE IN H.TOISRY
IDANWIYOF U  LLLET ME NET,OW L
ME YHO SW NOUOW SEOMDE SLI
S.WH
IEN DHE TUNBS C SYDA
MO
INRNGER INT JEWVI, WASHE
NDESRRPODT ENANE HND FOUHE TSECO
NTCUDOMESOS PE COMINLLG TTHAE W
ATSTJU SDRO AUNHE TAB TLE AND
W
WERE GO NGOI TLKWA TOUHRGH ALL
I ERWHE  HRSFITCH LADUN T ANDYHE
ULWODO TTHEEL BAG WHO SP
E
OIREWE GNG K TOD INOFO DHA T
BUTOTE H GNTO S IOHE T
MEDOCUS.NT
THES  ITH AOS PT BICRTLE THE
HEY,WA T W,0 200NDDSOR A W
I
GHTHOUTAS WAT GREMPE  HSILY
DNCOULLA E'TXP.IN
ATS I F THENTDAUNMEALSS IUE
HE.RE
LD CHEOUTN'ATOL TERIN LEOS
G
YMONEHEO S TIT LEGATEUSINSES
ASHE WGAK MIN CIOMIOMSSNON MEY
HEDAN W THETAR MKES ION DS HEE'
MA HNGISSSOM CMIN.IO
VEE THINMESTNTIS ADVYESUS BINS
N'DOT MONEAK M E OEYNRYVERA TDE
TBU CE HT LDOUN'ITVELI WHT I AND
THHAUT P TDL HTEANEIN IND A
I
GHTHOU WTHT ATAS AER VY GDOO
ONTCCAH HE TIRAR PT.
IS A ISCH LUNDEUT OSIIT WH
WHENE WER WVI LEEA.NG
LLU YOWI NICOTE TCTS HIPIEUR
LIUNKEHE T OIR FSTER ANEFT A
LE OYEAR WSEOU WLDAV HE
R GURELASNCLUHEHEND A TOT AN L
OFEX TTSA MESNDNGGI A-MAI
DAN YOUNO KW, SHEOS LT
$8LI M00ILNE IONN TH WTOR,
D
MI100  TIOLLNJUTHO E
ICSTE
ANTWO  ADAL HFLI BILONHI WH W
CH
0,000 TEN WTORSAW LYE AND
SHS THEOS MTIEES RILNT HANUM
INBEG ANDAD HO CPLAISNT
ITOUABT IT WH ME.
AIESH SD W ARORE FMS.UE QEN
WERERA AVEPL PGEEOE.
MI' N DRI BNGVI ATEA UP
A.
SHEOVED IONTN AMEPA ARTNT
ALENEVTU W ALYNDASIN PAYG2, $090
H,MOA NTHE S HAD T TON URIN
EREVYEC RPTEIVE O0 $R10ND S
S JU FUNNGIOCTNI.
TROURIS NEAIDRO FMNI BEREND A
TALSOLIELNG F ME SNKRALYHEAS W
UPTE HAE SDOM AAIFFRS SHE
UNFOD OUT AUTBOGUR DINHIS
WH
ROEOL PSSCE.
EYTHER WIN DEATGINCEWEHE TY RE
EARSLD.
THS IWND AREAD MF.OF
SHIRIIR GLFDEN I TSHENER PSO WHO
LETENT IOCC AO SES TA L OOTF
NDLEOP A WD TOLATE  MTH
SPDEEREIT HIE BEL TFO TEPHE DTH
OF SER HEL OUSHHTHO TUGWND ARE
S INCENTHEUT B SOL TD M IEF
WHICH IHO TASHTUG WYRE PTTT
AM
AINAZG SNDHEAS WE TRU TO
TH.
NTE SHSE L AATEETR PL COUE
S
OAGG AY SINVEE SHLOD THEOO BK
AN
DIC BASLYALHA TE EDNK MRFO
NGRSPUUI THE.RU TTH
ITHISSHA WT FAKSXEIM J AODLR
OU
THSE'ROHE T F PAG AND A
NA
GE T AND TT HAISHEEN SEVAG-PE
ACSPED L
TEETR.
E THESSTTLEERLD WOUOM CE OUT
RATIEALONIZ H BISR.AVEHIO
ONHE STH OER IEIDS ONE
SECEENTE LET A TROANRENDW D
INTHCAER YWHE OMT JOUUSNDAW S A
S  SITAYM I'SO,OR SRYVEOT N E
NO
VE BAD D JUSSO SNDRYOR A
THAS WIS HGYPO ALO.
HA'SAT WT CE HETLDOU GH
UT.
HERIS I WHENGTI TSEONAS PSIEAT
SE
GEN-VEPARSET LTEND ALD WOU
SE ITHION SNL OY A
ONEWR
ENSENTCETE LETAYRINI'MO
SO
TAYTHA SAS  LOT NOW
WTHISAS ANLCT AUA VTIICM ANDS
YOIL WLEE S AHE TSE ARELL
MAGILETI AND FIDITELYUN F
.
S.URRE TASKE MYART,RE TURASY
ILDETA. D WHE TRE SASOH MUC
SIEREVY HILENG T ONGNHI TE PSAG
VICTIMR O FM.IRF N TORHEEAM A OF
EYTHOU WLDOM CEFF STUH WEDIT
TR CATFIONRMNSIO.
LD WEYOU COM CEOGONHROLALICLY
IN ONDERRD A TAV GEMSIC VTI A
SE OEFO SER ORDED
ND A
CTSTRUED A RREMEMBEE HAI S
D
SE PHEAS ODN T ALLSEHO
MENAMAGES FNTEE BAUECSEASE H W
STJUG AK MINMMISONS HE
WALL R'TEANGMAY KIHE T
S SICION WHEASUS JTOI DNGHE T
INTRADG.
WHT TEHAOX BS I IS ERE ETH
CO
ONISMMSIPPS  ISUEDOSO TE B
STLI Y AEDNDL  WOUIL STINOCEEOM
OF THEANLA FGRTRT EEE HTID DN'
E QUITT.GE
WEERTHE O ARELSRA TDE
IRCONFS.TIMAON
THE WO  AASLSMANFCOIRONTIS
WITH TCE PHERISHA TN' DTIDT
TCMAHWH ANYARE ERNEANHE T R OGEF
AT DRA'SAY TO NGDI SERTHE WEER
WA.
THIS I OAY WK T IALUT ABO THE
TRT WSCHHI IHE WRETHVE ERYGIN
A
OS T SLE CARASITO  HO TE B
E.THER
HE HAD AYS SMTE TTHAWE SHO TDHE
E
RYSIPOTO ARU TSTNDOUF I Y
TTINOCES HIISM FROHE OAT DEF
NO0TERMB 3IL UHNT AITEC SUR
YO
ATISIONTHA TTE TIMST  IWAN I
DEERMB LO SLYERITALE H WAS
KIMANGP U
DSIPOTENT IO HERIS P
NASOL
ATUNCOT NOR MGA S ANLTAEY
ND
T ENTH INTO  TETH
AKETRK-MCOG INACTUN WCHHIAS W
INHEK BANF NEYORKHI WCH
WA
S AIMEG LITSIE ATBU BSSNEESK
NTO
BATHE R DCKOOF OHE TWE
-MRKMAET BINAKGSINUSESN ID HDE
N
ETHNGRA TDIFI PRONDHI T WSAS
PRNDOU B TAUECSEASREHE WN A
$8LI M00IL OONFT WHA LKEOOD
E
TRINADG L USEOSSHEILNT TON MEY
MPS WAPU IN.
BUOWHED L AHA TT,RENDW AND
MA
MRK SOFADFTO I WAS
INININIMATG C HOWHELDOU T NYOT
WN KVENOT THAE HAD HLL A
S
YMONEIL00 8 MS ONLI IOFLOA T
MOY.
WIASBL AFI TEO ER LNDITLYAL THE
N
ONPEE RSN I F THEATM IRTHAU SL
ETHCT AUCL UAVOH FTH WORHE HERE
HADN SEET  IDANSTHI TS YORIN IS
RAPCHTEHT EIG
HI TNKOU Y WLIL GIC A K
T
OFEA RTNGDI IND A WHA WTE
E
TIQUESERS ONTH AENDHE TIR FST
RMDETEN ATINIO F TONHESILAMY'
CIMPCOLITY O TNHEEDNO KWL OGEF
ETHEM SCH
NOS  TWHIT WISHAE HDAL CLEHE T
FI
.LE
LD WHEOURO POUSEMI YN IHI TS
1CASE FORHE SEA YRO
ERVENOMBT ND A ISHA YOUP UOR F
AB% TOU 9 O ASOLLUDAF  SE'NDE H
GT GOTOETOU YN I AON MTHHE T
RALIE TEL TTINSRALA T IONSO
PUSH UP.
SIT'SNGLAEXOR F SLUA
OUTEINRCE A WHAHET  WAS
DO IGNHE TIL FE P ISTIUTNG
WH
IEVATERLD WTOUE TAK IN THE
ESTRADSHO  TPU UOP THA TT
1%
H WHICYOANMES HT MUIG TAV HE
1SHOW%00N GAI TE GOIV8 1NER PSO
THE HSERO PMID AS TNDHI WAS
GOONG OR FEC D
ESAD.
E THESEARHE TCT ALUAFUT O OAT D
O
98 10 HHA TTE WASSI UNGIN DURG
TH65E $ONIL BLI
CA SM.
OOI T TKSEHEIC PRETUS.
BIETH FDUR TNEHEMAC BK TOHE T
ICREFONSSU CSONFIINLTG ND A
E  WEYERCKLOED T INSE CHELOT.TH
TH L MEO GDN  IANAK TE
OURCTES THEHI MAC.NE
TH
65KIN $ONIL BLI
HI MISAC I ANELLTS ID D IINPRT
OUT FEAK.TU SFF
THHESE' TDSPR SEAETHE TTHA WAS
FIUTDRE O EINRYVETH WGASAK FE
NTIS INGESERTI ISHE TRE W RHTASA
FUNDHA TTIE COP A M FUAUTLDUN
DANHA TTLUEIN LESEEP RRESNT
TUE THACALTSES RULROMHE T
TESTRAGYYO IF  IDIU DT
LE.MATITE
THDRE IIN LETHS EAKE RD.EA
NTINOCEO IENESNVTME  LTINOKLOS
LIKE
HA TT.
YOUW KNOTHHA WT  IS TT' IS
HE
W YK MS ESITQUIE RULEST
USBECAY TEHE HADIR THECC ANTOU
HETHWI TANM DY THE 4 HAD
83AC
UNCOTSH WITE.ER BNI
HA'SAT WE TH TOKS IRLO
LIE
TOVERTHAIM TE PANIOERD DT I
WE
NTP U I0% 2 WTHF EYEE ERTH
SAAT STRY.EG
SOOOKI ANGTHE T TUN FDTHA
'TULCODNAV HE BNE. DON
ISTHS I T INFOUS ANERAMIC
ESEXPRRG CSHAEHA TTHA CEDRG
T,05700ONTHA M.TH
ALE'ERS L OIN KDSKS FOLN I
THE HORMFI W BER WELYICASAL
G USINRME THFI AS AIG PGY BK.AN
IRTHE YON IS HEAS W CGRGHAIN
ZERSOL DLA ONTT  IBURY EVEDYBO
ASSEEL WNGUM JPINT IO IT.
RE IMBMEERONEN MTIT TEDHA
ACTAUNNT T IN M OHENEA IANN
ST
PRI
AL ML.
HHEAD ALL OFIS HTAAX T SSMP AND
ST ONAIORYLO OUTF NGDSL IAN
BEUSE  DRNBEIEID HIS
WN O.
HEYTHADLL A OF THEMEQU EIP
NTN
DT THAES  ITHS GUY NLSEAM AO
FO T IDNHE WSEEHAROUAS WLL A
DYNOBO WNO KWSHETHA TY ARE FOR
TBU TO  TMEPRY HERE TENESTHE
DENATERIOGRY TINIGO T FEUR OUT
HOO W TT T GEOUOFECT I BESEAU H
LDTOAT ME  TNDHE E W HEIN HASOP
ERTHEOU W BLDE AUC NARLEKTT AAC
N
STAL WL OETRE S IHA TTT WLDOU
PEWI A OUTLLF OIS HEC RDSOR.
TH'S H HOWEAS WNK THIG.IN
N'OU WLDURBET  SISPRED HF II
WAUY BOTGIN LRYTETSIC TKET
ETHE SAME TIMO T T TRYOUR FIG
EU
THOT W O GOETUTF O I
WNOISHI TS HE T ITIERNTNAAL
MODELAY UNTONGRI S.RY
TH
ISS ION S.IA
SHEAN RONHE T MEYERAU LNDGIN
NDNDFU AUN RS AAN BK INIAUS ATR
BATALLCAY NG MEYUT O O
FRU
OIASS TER HK BAN ANDN THEO T
ARNBEIE TNDHECA SRYNG THIS I
OKE SHLOSE LIKE.ER BNI
ALWE T EF  OANLVILM SOUE.AT
ALE'SHS ER NSOEV CEE BNLLMIRINAY
DARCHGEUT S HAD A O LOTF
NEMOY.
ITHISS HOW IED END.
I TEDIDECAOOHE T BK M TOYRAT FHE
OWH MAV GEMOTHE E LRAND FOUIOATN
ATTHEER BNIYOR SELAC LD.KE
IEI THI TS BOKAC TORLE EANHA TT
NENTMEIO H WDASISIMEG LITEAT
HOSTRE SECRYTA.
SH WASDSRI FENIT WH ALL
THE
S FOLKATTHAM C UEP ATHE T
AE
WTIMEHITHE TIR FMHEND A SD SAI
ENWHOM SE PPLEOE GO W ONEA OAYN
PAOMND A SEHE T OERTH. WAY
HEIN TND ENOT' IS  MANE ORTH A
MOALTYLI T T AENDGIRACHAT A T
T
YASOUNO KWK MARTTOM CMIED
IDSUICRE AE,NDWIEDFCE CANR
ANRE THEOTER WE R SCIDESS A
WE
SIDECITA TONO KET THAH, PVE EN
BE HIEAD LATITEGIM
AEND
GIILLEMATITE SO IST'EA R
YLA
ENTREMTOUSDO SRY AND IOP HT TEHA
GI YSOUTL L AIT OBIE TF A
FL
ORAVF O
IT.
HII T YNKL  WOUILNDFI IT F AUN
RE
AD ANDHEET G T MSAESGET THA
R
D IETOCRET G ASOS THA TTS
WANE A'  MANCHEMWA IE,T
A
REAI FLUHEF O TM.YS STE
B MUAYTUE SCKH WIT OOR MEMEF
USBECAFL NEET G IIXSTIETNGN ON
MYOO B I AKND'MSEUP SPODO TEA HR
LLTELIRARLAY TEIG TON
OHTR
RRTOMOOWO SAYOU Y MHIEE S TSN O
NEX.LI
OUATTH W BLDEIT EXCRG INFO A GUY
NATTH'SRIEREV WENTT AK. BOO
NYESDO AANDYBO WTO T SOTHOE SOM
QUONTIS AT ME?
WEAVE MESOIOUE QST INSNHE T
CTATCH A TLLUAYOTA SRT
IT .
ITHISNGDUS RIREHE T PIONTSEATN
H
YO D YOUNK THIHE TSE IRSESNVTO
DI ANAZEHE T SNTTETAMEHY W
DOPL PEOTI CEON BE NUTOE
BDLINEDSE TYHEZI PONCH SW
.
THEY LKOO SOIC OFF IL,IANOWU
TSOMETHAEN WT T EOUHRGHRYVE
NGSILETE STAECNTME BHESEAU T
Y
TBUTHE OHIERTH T INGS TTHAHI TS
S AIN ANFFYITRI CME5%ND A 8N
SHJEWI CRITI.ES
ISTHHO WLEWO NET WRKAS
COINICUNATGND AOI G TO- - I- -
N
WERVTEIEF JDEF MSTHATEWOD T.AY
HEANGE H AEDUN FD FYE 2OR3 SAR
ANUYO WNO KWT HAHE TOLMED ,
'SHE O ONEFHE TOS MTTON HES
PE IETE'V M.
HEDOLE ME H HAD0 8TONV IES
HOEROV T 2SE3EA YRSND A IN TSEHO
EA23 Y I ORSNERESNVTOED ASKIM H
EATWH H WAS DNGOI.
ONEFHE T OERTHSID D,H WITIS H
E
ONTAPUTI.
HIERN AAD PRIINSTE
TAREPUONTI.
HO TOE DSTHAEXC EUSUNHE T F
BEOREUS F MEHA TT ISHE T
QUESON.
THE WER PEI BNGDAI B TOE
EX
RTPE.
HTHEYED AADSKHE T QNSTUEIOND
VEEDFIT. I
DIERNN'IDTLL A AOWNY
PEINDEENT STODN.IA
AN IDEEPNDENTO CNTUSASANDI H THE
SEAST.
EY ARE TREHEND AY THEW KNOHE T
R
INADGS I T
REHE.
BEOUIERN WN'LDT AOWLLHA TTOR F
OBOUS SASREON ANDEV NER. DID
WOPPELETANO TLS AOEL BVEIE IT.
E THER LE ARA P OOTFPLE W
HOT
OMEW SHIETNGAS WIGTN' R
FRONNI RTUNAY,NG M IBE'MNG GOITE
TOEK OOTHTH OERAY WET LK L'SOO
H
ETH OEC DERIRNDONTI AHE T
THEREER WRSOTE HE WHON' DIDTN
THEY APL CREOMNITIC I THAA
SEE.
GU'YOVE U TOTOANERNDSTD THE
ST
.TERAGY
HENEES DIGD T ITTHA. WAY
HE WLDRY TO TXP EINLATU S
O
NONE OOU WER ULDNDANSTDT. I
BONODYD EE SMETO GETT. I
BYAYHE T W,HE T RYUN AUP GRON I
GTSHWAINONHA TS DTOEHA TT.
TH AOO LKT IENESNVTMUR RTETNS
ESDAN RTS A FIGE URITUT O
UPA INCO OF URS TBO AUTHEAM SE
TTIMESO LHEESNSER NEV GOTAC BK
TOXAHE T EONNAMITI OEA TM
TE
NDGROUEC BSEAU TERYHE WSOE
GHORTHOULYRD COO.ATINED
ATES MEVGESA NER GK BOTAC
ALG WITH ALU FAI.RE
IE HOP I ADWENSRE
HA TT.
KIND O-WLOF NGDEINDBE MAY.
I INKSY PICOLCHOGFLYAL I HE
GO
INT UB TRO M ALENDEAD
A
AKMIST AENDOO TK TNG WHERO
H
USBECAACHEE  LHEDKE TGEOU CRA T
O
TGE O OUTF B ITUTIDE H DT I AT
THAM SEIM TE,T' THASHE W INT
HAMECOS  TRDOND UDSTERANO S HEE
HAME TREOUNDS POFEROWS
TMMPCOARZATAENLIONTICH WHIY B
YE THWAADE H H NOIG INSHTVE EN
GHTHOUT IMS SEEIN KDF
APNTRE.
SONHEE HAS WUC SLSSCEFUND A
ENTHN'OU CLDCCT AOSTEP LGINN O
ETHTH OE, SERIDDNE  HDIW K'TNO
OATWH TO. D
THS I WREHEE HAC LKSOR REMSE
IS HD. MIN
INIS HIN MD HE WASURRE PSSED
SSNTLELEGR BLYY DYEE
IN
S.STVEOR
TH WTEDNSET RUR.
YSWAOS P
IVITE.
ADHE H TOEREL DIV
AD H HUNOFEDDRS ONIL MLI TSO
BUES HOMSEEC BAUULE  HCO'TDN
SAYO. N
SHEAWICHE T VM TIOFIS H
ORVEINST
AI SDO T ME IM A A PDUROCTF O
AREUL CTULLF  OWAEE STRTND AF I
O
VEU' NANEREV MEDAGHE TSS AS,
WYOU'TONNO KWHA W IT'MNGAL TKI
ABOU
ONEYTH DAY'T PHE TIR TESAX,
MEITHRSEYON I OESHFFORND A ALL
ASISTH W WASCTEF DLEGIN
SISPREON HLIBITY CET LDOUN'KETA
RELISIONBITY FIC BORASLYAL
AN
NGHI.
ITAS WS LW AAYEMESOONLS ESE'
FA
TULLWND A ASAYHE PUSD ON TO
SOLSEON EE.
WHE HD SAI TYER WED GEREY
IN
S,STVEORASHO W WHE TNER PSO
TELLG TMHET WHA THEUR RET
NS,
AREND MINAKG T UPHEET R
O WHSWAGIV GINHE TMTHVE ERYGIN
EYTHTE WANDE.ER BNI
DO YOUHI TNK HHA TTIS BGEST
IN KSTVEORHAWNE WET H WAS DNG
PE SORUSEDCT ANYINTHG?
HASCASROPI WFNE O OHE T BIG
FO.
TSHOR CH.ASELYUS KTHW ATT IAS W
EYTH B HLEAIDIMUT O
'SOT NY IK LELNEEYTH KWAST I W
ONA P SCHE B TAUECSEYHET LEF
H
REION MEYN. I
WHOOOU Y LUNDEHE TD HOO
TH
EYID DTT P AREY GDOO BOB J,
COMP CTELELYITPLOMICN IHE TAX T
FR
AYUACTLLTEIC DTADUT BHE T
SMF STLE OETHR FIGOUOT
DLYIDTE  HNOSTND UERDANHE TON
TESTRAE,GY H DAI SDEL'TON TL ME,
T DOI N'O NTWA THAOWKN WT IT I
DI>> NI BDERER EVEDAL TKE AUTBO
RISHI PN EXRIENCE ANDOW H
DI
A HDEAFUSDJT RTE LINGUC S
N
DINC IRE LEBLLEESIFTY?
E >> W EDNDI'TTA UNDP MUINLKG
B
HATOU TT B TAUECSE
HE
MPASSUASONTI W I T HADOOM CE
WNDORE THET A SOIEOM P ANTND
TH HHE TY MADE TLIELNG
T. I
BUT L WILAY ST  THA HRNBEIEAS A
MAARCHIS OMO, REE LFIK A
DFGRANY HEATRLD HENO KWSOW H
THEYHTHO TUG HEAS WOO CAU BLECSE
HEULLE OFFHI TS IBLRENCDIE
TH
G.IN
HI ISO TNKT THAS E  HWAINDOG ALL
RI
T.
OLHE FEVWELOD NGYTERHIUT ABOHE T
A
HE,SE TRT COUAS C.ES
LOYOU  ATHE SFFTUE HMEAV GE
AN I WEL UASNBEVAIEBLYEM MOR
RE
LLCA.
WAS RDIEANG ALLHE T
RIANTRSCS.PT
SOWA H,E INSTS AYVEG RY PGGLUED
.IN
H HHEADIS ATO SRY S HNDECKTUO T
IT
OUHE WIT ALDDMEO T MHE TON PZI
MESCHEHEND A T SHAFFTU T
HE
INCRIMDMLYAL A TTEITDETHA H
WOEVVED' NERTEDM AITT  TDHAIT
T
ONTEARD DAE YOR BEFE 12,99
EV.
HECKTU TO T STHARYTO AND
OF
COSEUR LT I TKEOODOE M LEIKT I
WANG GOIN OIN SCE THELY EAR
70s,E O S H NULCODEREVOM CE
N CLEA DD ANINO'TON KWHA THET
IDEREV D COM CEANO T H.SEIMLF
HEUG THOHT HE AUI BLTIMEG LITEAT
U
ANESISSND W HEGIN'AST NVE
EN
REGHOU CTDI FORHA T
SHIES INVRSTO ATNE PENTOI H
LDTOE MBO ANYDYHA TTHI TSNKT THA
YOOIRE A G TON EAR TWI TCE
R
SUEARYL BILAT RE,HE TYHO SDUL
KHAVEWNNOND ANE W IARDHE TM
AT IHE TREIS AS RKF O.RA FUDTH
GTHEHELOA TREOU CLD BAV HENEE
FR
D.
WHYTID DN'FIHE TY NDT? I
SITSANGE THATI FNICON
I
T DON'OWKNF IHI TS IONS C
YD
DYNOT BONO KWSHI TIS IST
YRGLAEL UOLD'SO  SITOFIN KD
O ODGO THETGE TOR WD A OUT
NDIN
TOER PVEECSPTI.
YHOI PE DOUO B B TYHEDK OOAN
T.ADRE I
ANDNE DIA'S BOOND INTENEPDE
BNA
ESTOKOROUO  YOUORSUR PP
LLOCAWIRE GENCH FM.IR
AN CEN SD TBO AONYT TDYHA
S
GNA SIEDK BOOAT L
W ARE TCOELMEACCOO NTIFT
NTU YOWAO T DAL TKYECIRTL AND
YOAN CNYSK A AIOUE QSTNS YOU
WA
NTBO ANYDY EE?LS
I ACTLLYAV HE AUE Q
IOST.
STINVENATIGIOFND A INY A L HAS
O
NY AOR REFMND A PSICOLIER O
OTHE.RSRGAESNVTIONTIS FOR
>> ITHATS G ADOOIOUE QSTN.
KE TVEALTABD OUHI TSEC BSEAU'
HES IHE TNE OT THAIC BASLYAL
RECOUNVETHD EON PZIE.CH SEM
AFLLITR  A WTENOW DY  TNHEDDI
LKTA ANDD SAI IE HERS VYOO G
DNO
W ATTIET DECNG PZIONCH SESEM
EYD ANTHOM CEVE ERYTH MON.
HEAI SON IDF ENEAP HPEO T
OFREHO.
REE ERMB W ALKTAEDHEUTBO T
MOIN CYOM IN,HI T W OSNEAS
FFNEDO O BORSHET TUTHA IS T
HEN
LYAY W.
NOW,TH OER R -OREFMS-N I THE
BOKE T IALDBO AUTOW HIP SC IS
OTHBONDEDWN AYUN R B THE
RYDUINSTND A TYHEUL SHO BDEAD ME
NDDEINPETENIK L TEHEC FDIND A
LYOPPRERALAP CIT
EDIZ.
ONI D'TNK THITHHA TT ETONV IESR
FUND S BULHODEBL ASA TEO YHE T
Y
DO DUEIL D.ENIGCE
ERTHEUL SHOOMBED  SAL LEEG
ENIRQUEMTSO S K HEE WSNO HDDI
LLFOOW S THENDPSTE AHE TSSS AET
DOXI EST.
ITDS NEE TOEEC BOME MOR
IVOAPRCTE.
PENK TLEHISHA TT'HA WTHE TCC F
O
.ES
INOTOM CES A INHEERFT TES M
SAN
S TRD IETOAN CLE UT IP.
TDOI N' KF WNO IUYO KOUW NOABT
RO BHON ODUTS IT'ER VYOT H
RIT. NOW
S  SITAYEY GEE FRE.RA TDE
THEYIR DTEC TDE THERA TO
EX IGEANSN R FURETNOR AEEB RAT
CAED PAYNT OERRD ALO FW
NDU
SESHO WNV I TTEENDS?HI
MRNBEIEOFF BUTE H DN'IDT
SCISW HEN CLI OTSN PCERI.
HE WAKAS TGIN S RHUC ATHATEBE AT
WTHEYEERNGET GTIRI PCE
IOECEXUT
TTOEN EHEXTTHT EYD PAI 3
OR
0 $4N LLMIIOIDD ANPATI T AUI
ECABEUSWEHE TY  G SREO TEDREYYHE
REWEIN TAKSOG UC MEY MHON.
WH
W DATOE ST  TAYHADO NO
.
IVMASSENGNG OOINGRA TDITS  INO
GGOINO TK. WOR
YORENG GOI TD SOENN I.RA TDE
TO
HEE M TY DOIOAN SCTN BY TUTHE
AR MILSTL AINAKG OLLFHE T
IRO
DY NEAN PMEAYNTOR F BHOT AND
BA TLLCAYOWFOO LLBOVE ERY
CFOF AFFLISEEC BAUYOHE WN
EY MKEONTR IN ISE ADTHS IOW HMA
IT H.PEAPNS
TH WRKMAETNG GASOIUTP U B T
E
Y U YOSAMI' A GIUENS'M I GNGOI
TO
OO GNND AOR BNEW ROMOY
ECABEUSHI TSS  ISO EY.AS
HAPPM, ENI'NG GOISEO  TLOLL AY M
NDYNE A F I'MCED SO TLEL
T
THAND  IATSHATNEAP HPENDD A
YOIN FD OUTOU YAN C'TEATHE T
ARKMAETND PLATIARCUHEYRL WYON U
AREN  IASURYO BENEMTUTIT WHO
SSCE T TOHENF IONMAORTI
E, M AHO TSERE THEYP TEY THEO
SH BLDERO PGCTTEINTONV IESRS
AN MINDOGE SFF UPRO F TO
WLOSCSEHITHE T FRAERE TNGDI
MALRELYNDNSEA AT THAY THERE A
RET NOSCNGWIIR THEMEUS CTO BRSY
NGGIVIHE TM INFIORCI PRI.NG
ETHESHI TEVSNG NERM SEE TO
Y TATOLLGO AYWANF UTETUORNALY.
HWHATE U THEADERNDGRTEUAND A
R
UAADTECH SLSOOON DEEG RDIARNG
DID B INIERE TACMPT WHEAYHE TY
EIN TRA?ED
>>ST HAWA THEST FIRAR PT?
ANDAC IMPT BN OSINUSESUL R?ES
>> OREA T EINCHGINICTHS
NEBUSI.SS
>>OUW KNOHA WTAD M MEE LGHAU,
MI' DNGOI AIR VALTUM ZOO TOHE T
ATIENRE BMNLUIYOD IE, JNUNND
YA GUSK AEDO  TINJO THEAN PEL
USBECA D HEEEA RIDESHRCH WIT A
HADARRO PSSORHO TKEALDO T
.RNBEIE
GULLWE, HASES WAV IT HBEE EN T
TTOKAL AUTBOHA TTRO P.SSFEOR
'S ARO PSSFEORF O E IICTHSN
THSSSIBUNEOO SCHHEANL D IE LD
O
EER BNIY BIN TAKCAHIG S SLL
T THWIOUGLLTEIN H AIMND INIS H
OKBOAS HE RND KEBEUT AIEBO
EWANDR'SEATHEND A HD SAI
IEBERNPOKEBOUTRT  IFOAL HF A
NDSECOND AHE TNWI SHETCD
TO
IN RRETESTESAT.
TH ISN AXA ELEMP O HFOW
SO
HIOPCIATER BS.E NIWA
T FIRS, AOFLLUYHE T GOL TDIM H
AS WN AVINT IER AEWUTBO
CSHI,OT NEC DIREY TLTH SEMCHE
DAN N THAASHET  WG AP TINIT
ATHEIERSA HNDE  IIDAS W O
EICSUIDCH WATIT WH TSO PHERI
NWH
EN A DRENDWD.IE
S TSOHIUY GS  IANIC ETH
SPR
R ESOFSODAN ID.NT IEN
URMI' SWI IET E CLLOM A ASIT B
OF A SE.PRURIS
TH SEAMRO P HSSFEORK B AOO
BOD THF OM THE HADAJ MOR
I IEWERNTVI O HEDIMN MY BHO SWUT
YO BOUSHLDEE ABL IO TDS NTEE
E TO BEDGRENAVN I THEREUL CTUF O
ELCH SOOOTND A NUS JT O
NECO
SE.
NTI WEO TUS A BSCESINS NOLHO I
RTMOH AND ITERS I V
LYURLTALOC FEDUSN O PEA TMYLA
ANDOI DNG THEIGHT NHI TNGOT
TACKBA SEAINBBG CHTH O.ER
I'TAK SPEOR F SEOMF O THE
.HEOTRS
YOHOOWKN W I'MAL TNGKIUT ABO.
>> LITKSOO TIK LE OS HIIS
LFINA QN.STUEIO
DID F YOUOUDIN YREENR TI
RIEXPE
CEEN?
BOSO MEDYSK A MEDE LHA TTEIK
RSFIT O IMYIN FD LFSE IN
THEOS MT VDIFILIEEN  ITH EIRNTE
ANPLET.
EYTHLL AST TRU TO BWIE THHE TIR
ESGALECIHEND A TKNY EW IHA TT
WAOI GPU TNGO UERS THETH TRU
.T
S ILYOT TAL S.REURAL
IT ISORTU HOUITSDIE ESEEF BOR
BETHMEK OOCOOUS TND A I O AM
CBND A NOWET NSIXFL I
REINTEED.
DTHERECIRTOOL TTH MDE I IATF
GO WHITIM HISN  ITHOC DRYENUMTA
I
BLLE SNEE 1 BYLI M00IL
ONPE
LEOP 2 IN8 DS.AY
, MEI AN'SITAL TOTLYALUR SRE.
THEC DEIRRTO IIN SSAYGEOPLE
ISAYAV HEO TOUET G YROO BK AND
I' SYISANGNGETOMHIROS I WNG
.HERE
ETH DRECIRTO B ISLYICASAL
INBEGGOMEG  TOR WK WHEHIT TM.
LDSHOU BT N'IT TEHEER OTH WAY
NDAROUSO, T I IS S.REURAL
AM DMYREAS WHI TSOU WLD B TEHE
TIFIDENIOU AVECCNTF OHERY STO
DAN U THEOLNTDTO SRY ATH OLLF
O
DULOM CE OUTND T INKHIHI TS
WILL EBE UNDP TGIN I INT PAR
BEADEUS MFOF IAS PWADSE AY
AN
OD NDOBL  WYILBE AE BLTO GET
TOT THAOFID SE  THEIOQU EAT
N.O
ULOP HEFLYS THI BK WLIL S.IT
FEON OY M ILSDO WHORO WTE THE
BO
OK EN OALONNR CDLE T
ARTES  GSTUYIN THEM ROOND A
R PETEO AISLS AEN FRI
D AN WTEOISTH TE STORF OE LIK
THISINAS W KDY F O MPEHO IIG M
E
EN  ITHOR MINGU LEA
E.TH
HA'SAT WT MYOP HES. I
HA TNK Y SO MHUC FORNGOI JNI
US
WE ALU SREO HAYCK TTE W GOT. YOU
O
UOIRE A GNGO TRYE  BVEUS BY
KTHANOU YONVE ERYORE FNGOI JNI
US.
GOOD NHTIG